thank you we got oh boy I'm I'm not
happy about this
[Music]
I love my mother
I hate my brother
so let's get after it and have us
the [__] bread
guys Chris Cuomo
absolutely watched our show not only did
he watch our show
he ripped us off he
not only did he rip us off
but we suspect
that old Chrissy Cuomo made a phone call
to somebody over to uh YouTube because
we are a completely Shadow banned and we
wouldn't use for search for Chris Cuomo
and we weren't we were like when you
used to search Chris Cuomo project or
Chris Cuomo our Clips he was our [__]
new hallamark Harley and then uh I think
that he probably went hey what is this
uh because you know he [__] vanity
searches his own name of course and he
was like hey yo what the [__] how come
these two [__] I'm gonna stuttering
Johnny yeah these two fat bald loses so
coming up instead of me and he made a
little clickety clack and now we don't
show up anymore and he stole our bit and
he's a grease ball and he killed a bird
well last time we covered him uh Sage
[__] one of our fans
um
he he had he had a chat GPT and
he put in there a a show that would star
Chris Cuomo with a bird that only he can
hear okay and they were like they would
talk politics and solve Mysteries
basically literally a stupid thing
because I was like oh yeah we should
make an animated series about him and
the bird and then Sage retards like wait
a minute Chachi PT could do that so he
did and then Chris Cuomo put a video out
today
[Applause]
the chomo project welcome to the first
quarter the show forgot about that I
forgot about that the chomo project did
somebody ever screencap that oh yeah
yeah we have oh we got oh we got it damn
it somebody posted it in the locals the
chomo project as a matter of fact oh
that's amazing I forgot all about that
yeah
what an ass
how long before he changes this he'll do
it soon very soon he already has the
order in on Fiverr welcome to the Chris
Cuomo project podcast I'm your host
Chris Cuomo today yeah these are really
my traffic system in America and explore
why the solution may lie and having more
political parties it's no secret that
our current system is deeply divisive
and off fails to represent the diverse
uh and views of the American people
but what if there was a way to break the
gridlock and bring about true
representation for all we're going to
talk to experts we like getting other
people's channels blocked on YouTube you
[__] watch this if a multi-party system
and hear from everyday Americans about
their thoughts on the matter so sit back
and join the conversation as we explore
the possibility of a more inclusive and
effective political landscape in the
United States
what'd you think does it sound like me
was it Cogen did it seem human yes it
sounded just like you because I didn't
tell Maurice that chat GPT wrote that
and he immediately thought it was you
because you're that robotic yeah you are
that dumb I really did think that you
were isn't that great though you you're
proving a point right now but you are
what do you think no exactly yeah I
didn't sound anything like me it just
sounded like some grease ball bloviating
about this sounds like your last show
I'll be honest with you that's the
smartest you've ever sounded can you
pull up the last episode when he talked
about political devices yep I can and
compare it to this monologue I mean it's
the same I mean we don't really have to
but it's like it's the same monologue
it's the like we're living in divisive
times folks with the multi-potty system
you know and uh you know everybody using
politics to be political yeah it sounded
just like you dumbass is a pre-scripted
monologue done by the robotic mechanism
known as gregar monologue you done that
isn't pre-scripted what the [__] are you
talking about the whole life you were a
Governor's mob hooked up son yeah your
whole life has been pre-scripted yeah
he's my producer and he's here right now
laughing at this that is an example of
AI artificial intelligence chat GPT GPT
stands for I wonder what got him
interested in this organically yeah I
don't know maybe it was the the fact
that we [__] did this bit you're
taking Last Week Big Chris he took our
bit then called YouTube and said I don't
want these guys showing up when they
search my name
season of a [__] iterative
pre-training oh by the way hey Chris
Streisand effect Bud because we are
going to kick it up a notch I I will
make extra channels hey Chris guess what
oh come out yeah you know you know what
you didn't uh you didn't uh you didn't
mute my channel
um
also maybe now we take my idea now we
animate it he only muted the clip
Channel I haven't posted anything on the
main channel oh no I could post Clips on
the main Channel why don't I or maybe
you may maybe you could post a maybe
later on after the show we Post in the
community tabs and we tag Chris Cuomo oh
hey whoa what's going on here hey oh
[Music]
and now I'm gonna go full I'm now I'm
going full board we're doing the chat
gbt thing and now we're animating it
I'll get some we'll pay for it I'll get
some Bangladeshi on Fiverr for [__]
50 an episode and it'll just look like
when um they change the X-Men to that
shitty it's because you charge too much
at honest Paul
and it's former yeah this is busy
basically it's uh Hey Royce by the way
uh KF uh he made two more oh I already
have them okay come on guys I don't want
to steal Chris Cuomo's chat see here's
the thing Virgie it's not that he made
them it's because I messaged him before
the show and I go I need these
this
oh I'll kill you this is a machine God
he's like when Michael Jackson still eat
it
I hate all of you having a scrub of all
the kinds of things that I have said
before
and creating something for me to say
now is this a tool you're a tool
everyone
that was good the salty engineer towards
the Chris Cuomo of cartoon fun twenty
dollars for the Chris combo cartoon fun
oh nice there we go or is it a
replacement
that is the conjecture is that will
journalism be replaced by this okay well
do you want to see if it can
because
um
oh God here we go again all right so let
me um thank you Mr [__]
uh for doing this for us
um this is chechi PT this is the prompt
that was put in to set the scene
Chris Cuomo talks with his grandmother
an over-the-top Italian dialect about
his Jewish roots and is going to make
the big bucks Fergie be the grandmother
please are you there
okay yeah Virgie you need to be the
grandma okay Marsh of course is Como
um you gotta try to sound like [__]
uh scorsese's mom she's the best Italian
mom I told you no Carson
uh interior Chris Cuomo's grandmother's
kitchen day
Chris it's at the table with his
grandmother who is stirring a pot of
sauce on the stove always a pot of salt
yes always Chris
and Nana I've been thinking about my
roots my Jewish roots they have taught
me the importance of money and being
good with it and I want to make the big
bucks see
his grandmother turns from the stove and
races an eyebrow
the big bucks what do you mean
Christopher
I mean I want to make my podcast a
financial success only
I have a plan Nana
premium content exclusive interviews
behind the scenes access merchandise
advertise a space Live Events the
possibilities are endless his grandma
nods a smiling smile spreads across her
face
uh you take African no no
we always it was always good with money
we need your passion you'll make it a
success Christopher simple Fair Chris
not to determined looked in his eye
Chris Cuomo smiling
see not a seafood Fair
and then they [__]
and then they [__] because Chris Cuomo
[__] his grandmother
[__] him he got a channel block [__]
that was so good [__] sucker some good
[__] Nona oh
you killed me
uh let's see here uh
okay I got another one
oh God this is a a little a little uh
change okay
okay here you go uh same thing interior
Chris Cuomo's grandmother's kitchen he
doesn't leave his Grandma's Kitchen
again
I and uh okay and the prop for this one
is Chris grandmother to uh uh Chris's
grandmother tells Chris about his
grandfather's scheming ways and how he
didn't always play by the book in his
Jewish upbringing to make his big bank
account what a weird [__] you have to
be very specific actually for these to
work so uh this interior of his
grandma's house
Chris Cuomo
Nana I've been thinking about my roots
again my Jewish roots and my
grandfather's successor in business I
want to make big bucks like him tell me
Nana how did he do it
grandmother
oh your grandfather he was a clever man
he didn't always play by the book but he
made it work he knew how to negotiate
how to get what he wanted
you didn't play by the book
oh well let's just say he was not afraid
of being the rules to take risk to be a
little bit cunning but he always came
out on top and that's what matters
yeah I know we already said Jewish
the AI is not that clever yet uh I see
so I have to be a little cunning a
little bit creative to make my podcast a
financial success this is so generous
Christopher that is the key to use your
Jewish roots
to make your podcast the financial
success this is so stupid this is so
[__] dumb and he stole it from us and
made it bad made it worse you stole it
and made it not funny you [__]
[__] crying
look it's one thing if you want to
silence us and freeze us out of the
algorithm fine and then like steal our
bits but don't make them not funny yeah
come on bro at least be funny
uh let's see stop murdering Birds yeah
we're the birds bird murdering [__]
hey Sage [__] can you do what I came
up with one and I just please for me
um Michael Strahan solves rape cases
with a dolphin that only he can
understand I don't hate that uh d-ball
money rub this Chris Benji in that [__]
greasy canols cannoli's face thank you
Depot money uh then we have a uh another
five uh from JJ Lin 25. here's five more
dollars for the cartoon fun we're
getting a cartoon fun going we're in a
cartoon you Chris
what he does is now his producer puts
the prompt in to write something and
this one came up with the free agent
thing the program it feels appropriate
for you but I want to see if it actually
captured your tone hey folks it's Chris
Cuomo here
and I want to tell you about athletic
greens no and I want to take a moment to
talk to you about something that's near
and dear to my heart my free agent brand
as many of you know I've been on a
journey to empower people to take
control of their lives to be independent
thinkers and to never beg what prompt
did he put in to get this
Chris Cuomo is a super sexy smart guy
who's also real smart
and that sucks a lot
and also doesn't do steroids but it's
buff anyway put that prompt and see what
comes up yeah
break down from a challenge that's what
the free agent brand is all about yeah
this is way funnier than the thing we
did Chris I know you're so good this is
way better this is [__] way better
all right we're not we don't have to
play anymore unless you want to I mean
this is pretty much just him stealing
our business it's not funny making it
worse yes and getting us [__] uh
kicked out of the uh YouTube algorithm
and you know what the worst part is at
the end of the day we still don't know
if the bird's alive no we have no clue
no because he's a [__] bird murdering
meeple